in the world of business the guy knows
what moves to make it seems like he's 15
moves ahead he knows his next five moves
all the time and when you look at the
companies he buys he bought whole foods
you're like
what what whole food you know you're
like okay
oh i got great brilliant
he buys twitch you know he buys you know
washington post why would you buy
washington post
i got it to control the narrative a
little bit of media if they're gonna
come after you've got a big platform
you've got a good place all this stuff
you're looking at what he buys prime all
these things that he goes through that
he built you know
zap zappos there's always a motive
behind where he's going
himself what's what's the motive behind
his hit
interest with mgm obviously we don't
know if the deal is going to get done or
not
but what is his motive behind the uh
what do you think is the motive behind
wanting to buy mgm
right well about a decade ago
let's start let's start here amazon is
the everything store
they want all their shelves full
infinite selection
and early on dvds um home movies
were one shelf of the everything store
you know and and that business starts to
decline
uh the sale of physical dvds is going
away so what what does amazon do it
starts a video on demand store
you can buy movies and stream and
download them
and then netflix comes along with a
subscription service
you know pay a certain amount per per
month and and watch anything you want
so amazon copies that bezos integrates
it into prime
it's free for prime members then amazon
and netflix are dueling
uh to license shows like friends or
seinfeld it's very expensive
it's you know hbo and showtime in the
80s and what they realize is it's less
expensive
more strategic to just make those shows
and movies themselves
so netflix and amazon get into the
production of
original tv shows and movies that's the
battle that we've seen now over many
years and mgm
is you know a huge catalog of the james
bond movies the survivor tv show
and uh the rocky movies the creed movies
amazon can plug into its vast catalog
of prime video that's a subscription
service they also have something called
imdb
tv which is a free streaming service
supported by ads
so in some ways mgm is you know a shot
of steroids into its in the into this
catalog
of content that could tie people closer
to the prime service
and when they're prime members or
they're using imdb tv
you know they're better amazon customers
they're buying more they're
buying kindles and alexas that's that's
essentially it um
it's this foot race that amazon has
engaged in with all these other
companies disney
apple um now hbo owned by time warner
being joined with discovery uh and
netflix and on and on
to own entertainment in the 21st century
got it so almost like how
disney disconnected themselves from you
know netflix and they went and created
their own
ott and it blew up i think it's the
fastest growing in the world
out of all the otts so he's thinking
about taking the mgm catalog and adding
it to amazon
you know uh what what is it called
amazon uh their own hulu they're on ott
there's a name yeah so pro prime video
and then imdb tv and then you know and
then also the original you know
mgm is a as a movie studio and and it's
got some interesting stuff coming out
um it it has the creed franchise and
amazon is in business you know with
um michael jordan the the actor um
and and so there's lots of avenues there
for amazon
to turbo charge it's it's video
offerings if it buys a conventional
studio yeah
it almost seems like he sits there and
he says oh
who can we go up against let's go
against netflix yeah that's cool uh
let's go let what we already took out
borders let's do barnes
how about walmart you know how about uh
well he just seeds no ground
right it's it's this belief that the
company that the you know that it needs
it should be everywhere where the
internet is offering opportunity
so he failed on the phone side which
means let's go up against apple and uh
you know android for instance okay
samsung he failed there fine do you
think he has anything
said in uh that he may want to go up
against the social
media world i'm talking facebook twitter
any of those guys
it's re that's really interesting
patrick because early on i
i found out that at one point he
actually had some of the earliest social
media patents
um and didn't do much with them and
um you know i think that's one area of
you know
with which they they haven't been that
aggressive um twitch is maybe the sort
of explicit
you know anomaly there but but that's a
little bit more of a youtube competitor
yeah it is
and tied closely to video games um
they've they have a
social network for books called
goodreads but they haven't done much
with it
so yeah that's one area where maybe
maybe
uh you know uniquely they haven't shown
much ambition
yeah i'd be curious to know because uh
you know
long term wise that's the one area where
you
almost need to have some control if you
want to have a so but we saw google try
to do google plus and it didn't work out
maybe he saw that as a playbook of well
it's not that easy to do
let's go different i don't know so and
by the way i mean maybe that's been
smart i mean they've grown an
advertising business without those
assets
and the social networks are in the
middle of a political storm that seems
unending now
and around free speech and political
expression and amazon
plenty of controversy and regulatory
attention but it's managed to skate
past that particular issue that's a
that's a very good point that's a very
good point you always see jack dorsey
zuck all those guys
you know always being grilled and i
don't know if he likes being grilled so
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]